Devon is with us in Monroe Louisiana
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show Devon
how are you doing today
better than I deserve how can I help um
I really don't know if I have a question
to tell you the truth what I'm what I'm
struggling with right now we have my
wife and I have our thousand dollars we
started this about that beginning last
summer and started with about 90,000 in
debt we've got it down to about 75 77
thousand we've kind of hit a lull and
I'm kind of looking for motivation
honestly to try and continue on with
this because I mean we have three little
girls and it's just kind of like a
struggle not you and what's your
household income right now it's forty
six thousand a year my wife is only one
working right now so my wife finishes
school in June she's gonna be an LPN and
then she'll get a job after that so that
will help tremendously obviously but
yeah it's going to Jack you just don't
double your income or mower yeah that's
and like I said there's still a couple
months away and we're just trying to I
guess we're just kind of trying to fight
our way til that country's you know okay
how many hours a week are you working
I'm on full time so I work for the
United States Postal Service so you
working forty hours yeah no more you
don't have a second job not right now
because she was in school you know she
does called our clinicals and then has
to come in and homework and stuff and we
don't have anyone else to watch the
girls no that's a good it's a good
investment of your time because
obviously she's gonna double your income
more than double your income come June
and hey you got that's just a few months
away your life's gonna be great you're
really great you know so all you got to
do right now for about sixty days just
tread water right and you've been more
than trade in water you've already paid
off 15,000 so very impressive thank you
oh you're doing good you're doing fine
you you have hit a law a little bit
because it's like you know you're
waiting on June kind of and you can kind
of see that and it makes it hard to push
on through and fight on through and but
you're doing all the stuff you need to
do you're on a budget right yeah
I would put some of you are you a visual
person I'm a visual person yes I am yeah
make yourself up a construction board
can you know one of those boards from
the like we used when we were kids in
school or something with a thermometer
on it and put the girls pictures all
over it and put we're doing it for them
we're changing our family tree and build
a thermometer for the debt reduction and
put on your refrigerator okay something
like that where you just you're you need
to be reminded of your why the reason
you started this was not just to be out
of debt you were getting out of that so
that oh yeah what's your so that to them
we make sure that they have the life
that we want to give them and better
than the ones we've had when we were
younger yeah we want to we want to show
them how to handle money and we want to
become wealthy so that we change our
family tree we retire with dignity and
we're outrageously generous and these
are the things we're doing right right
so write all that stuff down make some
notes and remind you because you know
you got to have something that bumps up
in your face to remind you of your why
if you got your Hawaii real clear and
your why is big enough you're looking
past the poop you're having to walk
through to get over there into the good
stuff right you guys even with her
doubling your income you guys got
another 18 months of poop to walk
through and your be debt-free yeah
you're not then you're gonna be
debt-free and then you're gonna be
making like $100,000 a year household
income or more and you're gonna have no
payments Your Honor I don't even know
how to act I mean we really are and we
talked about that quite a bit
honestly um I mean we're just outside of
under Louisiana or in Southeast Arkansas
state line so it means because the
living here is really low yeah and with
that kind of income it just excites us
to try and push for it but it's just
such a struggle to even you know see the
finish line I think yeah yeah the good
news is is that maybe for the first time
in your lives you have a finish line
most people don't even know where the
finish line is
I'm really proud of you I think you're
doing good stuff man keep scratching
keep clawing